Easter Egg Easter Egg to do that I
didn't turn in an incinerator
hello welcome to Playstation grenades
did you know that just cause ball came
out this week course she did well I'm
currently looking for Easter eggs in the
game but I wanted to showcase a few of
the reasons that I absolutely love this
bloody game and yet travel yes shooting
but there's something else which makes
me love this and it's the physics
because we have a few different things
we can do this one you just sort of
tethers things together drags them
towards one another it's ridiculously
fun let's try something for the second
one the second thing we've got ah like
little air pockets little air balloons
it's like a fulton system would you play
Metal Gear Solid and let's just connect
close to this I don't know if this will
work I've never tried it on a satellite
dish but if we have an annoyance seat of
antigravity from these balloons bloody
great is that I love it so much and if
we can get it to drop on top of the
helicopter I just press it down on the
d-pad when I'm ready and I've missed it
completely yes well done Adam okay so
we've looked at two of them the tether
and the ballooned we can also put on the
is to tether again but it has like an
electric sort of booster some sort of
turbo booster apply to it you ready for
this let's try and get another one
nobody's it it's pretty good how that
works
so basically it's just a playground of
physics so whatever you can imagine
pretty much you can do let's see we can
take this for a little supply there he
goes
go on break free my pretty break free
yeah so just cause for it's just like
just car three but it's more reliable I
adore it I really do
right you John that let's see if this
works
oh he's so good oh if he gets dizzy you
see the the NPC's usually talk if you
stand near them long enough come on dude
say something no fellow we will not get
it off we can apply what was a good
fight going on we can put balloons know
what we'll put some of those projectiles
on him and we'll see if we can make it
spinning faster what about take this to
the sky get some evidence
[Music]
hmm came back down again
alright give me a second me say music
more balloons fly ball goddamn sake
there we go that's better the pillion
fall in the sky right projectile let's
see what it goes boys off wait for me
daddy do you think he survived did you
think he had a chance he might be still
all right
I know nope he definitely didn't survive
oh well yeah definitely anyway billion
ball go be free be one with nature we
will meet again one day what else
so we basically you have to go to these
different bases and take out anything
just anything that's white and red so
we'll just need to get rid of this guy
will use a tether so we usually tether
to attract it over here to pull it
towards the ground
simple as peace where do you need me to
generators weed you have to go
to the guy down here
and then we send the money way jetpack
hey you join the jetpack guy
great are they tethered oh no the cone
came with him the Cody's not tethered to
the ground I could watch this all day
I'm that Sam I could really watch this
all day
hey you join your friend in the sky open
the way up under higher and the
completely alive by the way so if there
the forms are too much they will survive
it I don't think he's survived that one
you alright boss I didn't matter she's
hardcore
you know the score survive that anyone
oh my word
survived again right you are going to be
an astronaut you're then good at this
hola hola right fly my pretty go on
skyward what the hell did he go let's
see Kyung do you think de-spawn or do
you think he just troubled too
hey you go find your friend you probably
went this guy would like that tell me
when you find yeah Wow yeah this is this
is quite a big step up from just go
three and this used to really glitter
let's go and random things like that
happen pointman things blow up all the
time
I'm on a boat i'm on a boat
[Music]
i'm on a boat i'm on a boat wildlife
what shall we do with d wildlife hey
oops
Oh a balloon of your foot fly my
pretties haha I feel like this is this
some sort of joke here what did the
buffalo say to his son before school
bison I know a little brown cow whoo
that was nice you can join me in the
revolution you got any more friends
there's another one it's three we got
three counts you steer and you there we
have it
where did the other one go what are you
going car Jesus
okay we mark mark up amid more cattle
you can can this fly with two balloons
and two cows it can hey I'm working hard
today working very hard I want to play a
goat you can join the aerial farm
we just need some all anonymous good
pretty good Oh piggies we all know about
takes it fly that's work of art it
really is a work about another goal okay
then I must ignore that you know that
one right join us come on this is
gorgeous so I know this is the question
you've all been asking yourselves can we
get from the car which is in this car
that didn't go well one two three four
five I've missed it damn it
oh well we'll do it before instead let's
get on get on board come on here we go
Animal Farm in the sky who needs the
real game when you can do this instead
causing pileups below you don't see this
very often will it knock me out oh no
I'm pretty cold Rodriguez try again
[ __ ] all right lads shoot just
learn how to use your break travel in
your horn this isn't an iron in the
slightest it's fine I will move my
Craven Epis oh hello dear
need to pop it just before we get in now
lit it James Bond dad - daddy don't
delete ma ma ma nice just cause in a
nutshell honestly this game is just it's
broken in the nicest and greatest ways
possible become oh oh
anybody want to barbecue alright this is
the last time I promise I promise I'll
be quick as I can I want to see what
happens if we put all these air balloon
animals and then use one of those
nitrous boosters will we propel through
the air or will we just spin on an axis
will we go forwards backwards around in
circles one way to find out just cause
for this is what happens in just cause
for but it's worth it
[Music]
oh if stabilized we've stabilized and
we're off again
hi welcome to Playstation grenade today
spinning in circles epileptic epileptic
fit epileptic oh my word I'm dizzy after
that one what hag is this app an app and
have we just found an easter egg
anything for your weight this is awesome
why do you think this is a reference to
the games where you hid the head with a
pan this is quite addicting whoa Easter
[Music]
dinner there's a woman like the video
like the video
Oh
I don't know the words so meet with me
she gonna dance does she sing does she
choose that one bogey no I'm the kind of
guy just runs around the dumb flow yeah
oh I'm gonna get demonetised if I put
this in a video I don't know
[Music]
let's make this woman can you tell why I
don't like to stream I just washed that
back and I am so embarrassed anyway
thank you very much for watching it's
much appreciated if you want to see some
more gameplay footage you just give me a
shout tell me in the comments if you
want more and if you want less tell me -
because I will never learn the time the
most annoying person in the world unless
you tell me in fact what comments
sections are for isn't it to be toxic
anyway it's been a pleasure thanks for
watching I'll see you next time mr. Mike
oh my god I'm still going opera in